hey guys I'm Kristian harloff I'm Dan
parole somehow we were at the Oscars and
it's about to go down right now Tom
Hardy Tom do you see how cool Tom Hardy
is how crazy coming back to the Oscars
again what's the experience like for you
oh it's mean it's incredible it's such a
bustin I had such great talent yeah you
know it was wonderful it's really cool
are there any characters from this
year's Oscar films that could take on
Superman in a fight
no Lia from the Revenue I don't know
that guy's got a lot of gumption
Superman's invulnerable Strait point
shirley's oh my good lord have you
prepared your speech we're just gonna
wing it
well I prepared my speech for the Golden
Globes and we didn't win and then I
prepared my speech for the producers
Geller we didn't win so I've got one
ready to rock I'm gonna be looking
forward to it like on the carpet will
you would you like to give your Golden
Globe speech right now
you know I can cuz that cuz I was gonna
use it tonight
this is our first time in the Oscars
we're movie fans first and foremost we
don't doctor I figured okay yep good
night this is actually goes into the
question here who would you most likely
scream at in a movie I'm gonna say you
have a just a slightly more scream
animal face yeah I mean I mean you
you're very scream aníbal so it's really
a matter of degrees appreciate it
slightly well both if I had the
opportunity to scream at the both of us
okay well you do by the way if you want
to you're free to one of the most
important bumps on an actor's career is
if you lose and the camera is still on
you that's very important acting yeah
can you give me the I just lost face
yeah forever you won last year which
makes you more nervous accepting an
Oscar or presenting an Oscar
Oh accepting an Oscar yeah it's free la
she's gonna win the Oscar breathe gotta
get one just one she looked at me and
ignoring me bet I have hope Jacob
Tremblay he's the kid from room not the
room but room it's an amazing movie he
should have been nominated the kids
right there he has accomplished more in
his eight or nine years and Dan and I
will ever accomplish in our lives la
Marck just keep on doing what you're
doing
hey thanks positivity puppy that's it
for us on the red carpet we had the most
fun uh JK Simmons was here I hugged
Superman we talked to Superman and
remade himself Andy Serkis as movie fans
we like this this is crazy this is such
a great experience to be here how much
fun was this maybe a 10 of 10 and I
rarely say that this was incredible so
for movie clips and Fandango I'm
Kristian harloff I'm damn proud we'll
see you next year